this is a simple trip this is not an  Arctic expedition this is a an Arctic  brain break make it real tight as you're  bouncing around it will have a tendency  and it will back itself out in order for  this to work you know you kind of have  to marry the two up this is too small to  do much it won't let it flex I do that  so I'm gonna look for a little bit  bigger one for the handiest little  things in camp these little clintus pins  they help me do so much from rigging  things to pull lift whatever clothes and  this is the art of being su is it the  right way some Boy Wonder in a shop was  going to do it probably nothing but  Susie thinks she's all that inside of  Fry's wishing him  got me kidding me right this one's too  wide for my app  I want to get the hell out of camp  because I do  get the ice off of there  but uh  it will now pull my slip  you